the super-sized food delivery that took  a texas mom totally by surprise kelsey  golden she says that she was working on  her computer at home and didn't realize  that her two-year-old son had grabbed  the phone and was using it we know where  this is going he usually likes to take  pictures of himself  and so he was doing that  and he um  i thought i locked the phone  but apparently i didn't because uh the  doordash came with 31 cheeseburgers  that's the origin story of the  hamburglar right there um that's right  barrett ordered 31 burgers from  mcdonald's uh they cost 91 dollars and  70 cents including the tip got a tip i'm  glad he tipped good on him got a tip of  course now listen i'm trying to get my  summer body ready whatever somebody  accidentally ordered 31 cheeseburgers  that's just divine you can't waste it  you've got to eat at all we can't waste  that no he's  hot you'd have to eat three or four  at least  it could have been a lot worse yeah no  91 she got off easy yeah